La volta al món a peu, dia 243.
Em trobo a Tbilisi, capital de Jòrgia,
i avui entrevistaré a Pau Campos,
un català que viu, crec que parcialment, a Jòrgia,
i serà un altre català sense fronteres.
Ja sabeu que un dels reptes és entrevistar
a un català que visqui per cada país que vaig.
No ha sigut fàcil, eh?, trobar un català a Jòrgia,
perquè que tenen relació amb Jòrgia, sí,
però que visquin aquí, crec que, clar,
és un país que és complicat, no?
Eh, han de terminar les coses.
Bé, a veure què ens explica.
Ara mateix tenim el Pau concentrat
en la selecció georgiana d'en Bol,
que és la seva feina,
i diu que està a punt de baixar.
Home, Pau, ja el tenim aquí, té.
Saps posar-te el micròfon?
No, no m'he posat mai un micròfon.
Mira, té un imant, i te'l poses com...
Ah, d'acord.
L'imant darrere.
Ok.
Anem a dalt, que estarem bé a la terrassa.
Ah, perfecte, molt millor.
Molt bé, doncs estem aquí a la terrassa de l'hotel,
vosaltres no ho veieu,
però tenim vistes a totes les xarxes.
A totes les ciutats, genial.
Pau Campos, véns del Barça,
ja és la tercera persona que entrevisto
en aquest viatge que ve d'aquest món, eh?
Sí, vinc del món de l'en Bol, correcte, sí.
Havia treballat al Barça,
ara estic actualment treballant a Bordils,
el poble on sempre he desenvolupat la meva carrera
com a entrenador,
i ara estem col·laborant aquí
amb la Federació de Georgia d'en Bol.
Ostres, és una potència de l'en Bol, Georgia?
No em sona.
No, no és una potència.
Ara, actualment, penseu que és un país molt petit,
té 3 milions i mig d'habitants, com tu saps,
i el principal esport aquí és el futbol.
El futbol, que el seu principal jugador
és el Cabras Kelly, que ara és jugador del PSG
i que es diu campió d'Europa.
El segon esport principal aquí és el bàsquet,
que tenim al Barça, precisament, tenim un pivot
que és Georgia, el Shangheli,
és un pivot que és Georgia,
i el tercer esport estaria a la part
entre l'en Bol i el rugby.
I l'en Bol és considerat aquí un esport
molt prorrus, tu saps la situació.
Sí, tu saps la situació que hi ha una mica
que Georgia vol, bueno, marcar moltes vegades
la seva independència del que seria
l'antiga Unió Soviètica,
i l'en Bol aquí encara es considera com una
cosa que veu molt de l'antiga Rússia.
En canvi, va entrar molt fort al bàsquet,
perquè el bàsquet es veu com un esport molt occidental.
NBA, Amèrica,
una altra història.
I això fa que ara hi hagi més
gent pro-bàsquet que no d'esport a l'en Bol.
La federació georgiana d'en Bol
està intentant donar-li la volta a això,
i per això intenta...
Tampoc em sona que sigui un esport molt rus, l'en Bol.
No, durant els anys 80, a Rússia era una potència amb l'en Bol.
Els olaurs, 80,
90, el César Camins...
De fet, molts jugadors russos van acabar jugant a la Lliga Espanyola.
I era una potència.
Ara, evidentment, tot això s'ha trencat.
Com acabes aquí? Perquè, clar...
Doncs mira...
El contacte amb ells?
Sí, el director tècnic actual de la federació georgiana
havia jugat a bordils
amb mi com a jugador.
Era un jugador d'aquests que havia donat voltes pel món.
Georgià.
I havia jugat allà com un jugador estranger que jugava a bordils.
Vam compartir vestuari.
Després vam tenir contacte.
Un cop ell va marxar,
va dir que no volia jugar a bordils.
I va dir que no volia jugar a bordils.
I va dir que no volia seguir contacte.
Jo vaig estar treballant de director tècnic de la Federació Catalana d'Embol
i ell va entrar aquí de director tècnic de la Federació georgiana.
I va dir que havíem de fer alguna cosa junts,
hem de provar de fer algun conveni,
de xinèsies junts i tot.
I va arribar la pandèmia.
La pandèmia va parar tot.
Jo vaig sortir de la Federació Catalana d'Embol,
vaig tornar a bordils i quan es va tornar a obrir tot
li vaig dir que havíem de fer coses
però no cal que sigui a través de la federació.
I va començar un vincle molt xulo.
Primer van venir ells a conèixer com treballàvem,
els va agradar com treballàvem
i van dir que hi hauria la possibilitat que vinguéssiu vosaltres
i ja és el terci estiu que estem aquí
i que tenim activitats conjuntes.
Tu ara mateix estàs entrenant l'equip absolut
de l'amnistia masculí?
Això ha sigut ara. Vaig començar per la base,
vaig començar entrenant cadets,
després aquests cadets també van ser juvenils
i entrenava cadets i juvenils
i ara fa dos mesos que ens van proposar
agafar la selecció absoluta masculina.
Que és una selecció que els dos últims europeus
ha participat, si s'ha classificat per l'europeu
i que és l'objectiu que ens marquen, classificar-nos per l'europeu.
Ja no guanyar un partit a dins de l'europeu,
que ja seria un plus,
però perquè es fa una idea, el primer cop que la selecció
d'en Bol d'aquí es va classificar per l'europeu,
quan van tornar, els va rebre
el president del país i els va donar
una medalla d'or al mèrit esportiu
en representació. És molt important
per ells col·locar la bandera georgiana
a l'esfera internacional.
I llavors estàs aquí quants dies a l'any?
Doncs mira, vaig venir una setmana
al maig,
aquest any molts dies,
vaig tenir una setmana sencera al maig,
que vam fer una setmana amb l'absoluta,
vam venir després una segona setmana al final de juny,
principi de juliol, i ara estem 15 dies.
Després farem un altre campus
al novembre, però que ens desplacem
a Noruega a jugar contra Noruega, hi ha partits oficials,
i el gener torna a venir.
Són diferents estades, campus,
estàix, que podríem dir, en diferents moments de l'any.
Els georgians són molt forts,
és a dir, ells guanyen moltes competicions
de lluita. Correcte.
No sé si això afecta l'en Bol
en el sentit que, ostres...
Sí, sí, sí, el bàsquet i l'en Bol,
o el voleibol,
són esports on l'alçada i el pes
tenen molta importància.
I aquí, precisament, la zona de les muntanyes,
que segur que ja ho hauràs conegut o ho coneixeràs,
és una zona on els homes
i les dones d'allà, genèticament,
són molt alts i molt forts.
Antropomètricament són molt alts
i realment són gent que són molt interessants
per aquests esports de contacte.
I a més a més, com tu dius, són molt forts i no refusen el contacte,
i la lluita per ells
és un esport molt, molt important.
De fet, són campions olímpics en judo,
i són campions olímpics en lluita grecorromana.
Exacte.
I són esports de lluita.
I ells tenen aquest concepte de no refusar el contacte,
anar amb el contacte.
El rugby, l'embol, tots aquests esports, això hi va molt acompanyat.
Jo l'altre dia comentava en un vídeo
que el fet d'aquest que els hi hagi la lluita,
jo crec que això
és una manera de ser
que diu moltes coses, potser, del país.
Com diries que són els georgians,
sobretot els homes, en aquest cas,
que són els que lluiten més?
Sí, són freds.
Són molt...
no diuen dues paraules
si poden solsonar-ho amb una.
Són molt tancats.
Després, un cop entres, un cop trenques
aquesta barrera emocional,
són molt bons anfitrions,
estan molt orgullosos del seu país,
són molt nacionalistes,
i volen que tu marxis aquí parlant molt bé del seu país.
Però realment, fins que no acabes
de trencar aquesta cuirassa, ells et veuen sempre
com una amenaça.
Són molt poc emocionals.
Si tu els hi fas una abraçada o els hi fas qualsevol cosa,
es queden com, què estàs fent?
Tot i que després, a canvi, quan se saluden,
es donen la malla i es fan un petó.
Entre els homes també ho fan.
Però clar, sí, entre ells.
Amb nosaltres es donen la malla i es marquen una certa distància.
I quan ja s'acosten i et fan com un petó,
home, home, et fan un petó a l'aquí a la galta,
és com si haguessis traspassat
ja una barrera emocional amb ells.
Com has començat a fer aquestes col·laboracions
fa quants anys?
Tres anys.
Jo vaig venir l'any passat,
un any de diferència, i he vist algunes coses canviades.
Jo crec que és un país que està creixent molt.
Molt, molt, sí.
Aquí a Old Tbilisi, que és la part antiga de la ciutat,
hi ha un pàrquing molt gran al principi.
Els primers anys que veníem hi havia molt poca gent,
molt poc moviment.
Ara estem a l'agost, evidentment és temporada alta,
i ara és un formiguer de furgonetes de lloguer,
cotxes de lloguer, conductors que t'ofereixen
per portar excursions a les muntanyes,
que et porten a Cajeti, que et porten a Tabatumi.
O sigui, està fent un auge turístic bastant important.
I es veu molta gent que no està preparada
per viure del món del turisme,
que vol viure del món del turisme.
I hi ha una cosa que és molt important,
que és una mica aquella lluita de dir
no ets un conductor professional,
però tu m'ofereixes portar-me 8 hores d'aquí.
Bueno, una miqueta el país està creixent.
Has conduït per Georgia, tu?
No, no he conduït, m'han portat sempre.
No sé si és pitjor, eh?
Perquè clar, si et porten,
estàs a expenses d'un conductor jaurgeà.
I per mi són psicòpates, eh?
Sí, sí, sí.
No hi ha línies marcades, val tot.
Mòbil a la mà.
Sí, sí, sí, totalment.
Totalment, la velocitat no és important.
Sí, sí, fan qualsevol gir en qualsevol moment.
Nosaltres riem,
perquè sempre diem que quan ens venen a buscar el pavelló,
quan surten del pavelló,
hi ha dos carrils en cada direcció
i no hi ha hagut dia que no hagin travessat els dos carrils,
travessant-los de manera perpendicular
i, evidentment, ningú pita,
o sigui, ells posen el morro de la furgoneta i ja està.
És una cosa bastant peculiar d'aquí, sí.
Hi ha diferències entre la gent de Tiblís
i la gent més rural, de poble, i tal?
Sí, sí.
És semblant...
Jo he estat també treballant professionalment a Romania
i és semblant a Romania fa 8-9 anys que vam estar allà.
No és que no hi hagi hagut capaix.
No hi ha classe mitjana.
Hi ha classe alta, perquè aquí pots veure Lamborghinis
pel carrer, pots veure un Porsche Cayenne
o pots veure, per no dir marques,
però pots veure cotxes de nivell adquisitiu
i després veus gent que no té cotxe
o gent que té cotxes que estan 20 anys
i que van d'estar atalats.
I les cases, igual.
Aquí al nostre voltant,
ara suposo que faràs algun plano,
hi veus hotels, veus cases totalment remodelades
i al costat, façana per façana,
cases que estem gairebé esperant que caiguin
abans d'andar a rocar.
I això es nota.
De poble i rural, molt més.
Al rural encara funciona molt
el tema de l'intercanvi.
Què tens tu, què tinc jo
i no cal ni pagar, fem una mica d'intercanvi.
I ja, evidentment, tot va molt més a poc a poc.
Aquí a la ciutat, l'entrada de turisme,
l'entrada d'empreses, empresaris nous
i la proximitat a Europa
vol acostar a Georgia cap allà
fa que hi hagi un altre tipus
de tipologia de persona.
Tu has fet turisme una mica per aquí?
Poquet ens han ensenyat.
Què t'ha agradat més?
A veure, mira,
de dissabte marxem cap a Tel Aviv,
que és una altra ciutat important d'aquí,
que és més a l'est,
i la zona del Cajeti, tothom ens ha parlat molt bé
d'aquesta zona de Cajeti,
que és una zona que diuen ells de molt bons vins
i que estan molt orgullosos.
I he anat a veure també esglésies,
les esglésies, tot el que sigui.
Aquí hi ha una barreja molt important de cultures.
Hi ha gent musulmana, hi ha gent cristiana,
hi ha gent ortodoxa, hi ha gent de moltes religions.
I ens van portar a veure
l'església més antiga,
i que va ser la primera, consideren,
la primera església cristiana que va entrar al país.
Que és una església que està
a 20 minuts de Tbilisi,
que s'aguanta per vestides,
s'aguanta justeta, és tota de fusta,
és maquíssima, és preciosa,
i entres a dins, i si ets turista
t'hi sents malament, perquè hi ha gent que és devota,
que està allà practicant la religió.
No vas a Montmartre,
a Notre-Dame, a París, que és plena de turistes,
o al Pilar, a Saragossa,
que està plena de turistes.
Aquí hi ha gent devota que està exercint
la seva religió.
A tu t'agrada, Jorge?
M'agrada, Jorge. És un país xulo, de molt de contrastos,
la veritat és que la nostra situació
aquí és molt fàcil.
Si et fessin una oferta, tipus, ei, volem que siguis
imaginari, no?, l'entrenador de l'absoluta
i visquis aquí de manera permanent.
M'ho pensaria, m'ho pensaria, perquè tinc família a Catalunya,
tinc família a Catalunya.
És que ara m'estic pensant
amb l'altre jugador d'embol que vaig entrevistar a Istambul,
que li vam fer una oferta molt bona
i se'n va anar a Istambul.
I vam moure tot, no?
Com t'ho veus, vivint aquí? Una mica complicat?
Jo tinc família, tinc dos...
Bé, de fet, el meu fill està aquí aquesta setmana amb mi,
m'ha acompanyat en aquest campus, que és també un campus del Barça,
i l'he portat cap aquí
perquè visqui l'experiència. Però com per viure
12 mesos aquí, o ve tota la família,
o jo no vinc, això és indispensable,
i després és
un país per viure complicat.
És un país per viure complicat. Tot i que estiguis
a la franja alta, perquè per sort estiguis a la franja alta,
és un país complicat, com tu dius,
de comunicacions, de moviment...
Nosaltres venim d'un país del primer món,
d'Europa, i clar, és diferent.
Abans parlàvem de l'AMBO,
la influència russa, tal...
Això, no sé...
Clar, ara hi ha molt tema que, clar,
ells tenen un problema amb
que Rússia va envair dos parts
del país, però a la vegada
el president actual,
d'una mica de megatotis, està fent... és una mica
prorrus. Correcte.
No sé si vols parlar d'aquest tema, perquè clar... Sí, sí, sí.
Ho he parlat des de la meva ignorància.
Estan fent lleis una mica
contra la llibertat d'expressió, no pots criticar el govern,
aquest tipus de coses... Sí, és una mica
de l'acord
d'aquests països més
potser ultradreta, no?, o de dretes,
on ja es persegueix
una mica de llibertat d'expressió,
i aquí hi ha hagut manifestacions, el primer any que vam arribar hi havia manifestacions
al carrer molt, molt
freqüents, de la part que era
pro-europea. Hi havia càrregues
policials, però hi havia càrregues policials molt
fortes, i els manifestants ja anaven
preparats per aquestes càrregues policials,
i ells el que estaven defensant, el que volien era,
just abans de les eleccions, que semblava que
anava a guanyar aquest president, que és més prorrus
que proeuropeu,
doncs volien defensar la possibilitat
d'entrar a la comunitat europea, que per ells
era com una mica la salvació. Si veus pintades
pels carrers,
i hi ha molts, molts llocs
que estan banderes europees
penjades, però l'actual
president, votat,
evidentment votat, sobretot per les zones rurals,
les zones rurals són més prorusses,
i les grans capitals són més proeuropees,
el que dèiem abans dels contrastos.
I sí que és veritat que la comunitat europea
va intentar, bueno,
les grans potències, tant Rússia
està intentant
estirar-los cap a la seva banda, com Europa
està intentant estirar-los cap a la seva banda.
I està en aquell moment de
cap on anem, cap on anem.
I a les ciutats es parla molt que volen anar a Europa,
comunitat europea, que entri
diner d'Europa aquí, i les pobles
prefereixen ser més fidels
a les seves tradicions prorusses.
I com tu dius, hi ha una part del país que ells dibuixen al mapa
que el georgià no pot entrar.
Ells dibuixen una part, la part
nord-est del país, que dona
el mar nord, ells no poden
entrar amb passaport georgià. Tu i jo podem entrar com a turistes,
però ells no poden creuar aquella frontera,
tot i que ells la dibuixen dintre del seu mapa, encara.
És curiós. El Google Map ha estat dibuixat
com a georgià,
però amb una línia discontinua, com dient.
Sí, però no.
Bueno, és una mica el que va passar a Crimea, però aquí ningú va moure un dit
per ells. Això també ho diuen, que
quan van envair Crimea, tota la comunitat europea es va
posar a sobre i van intentar enviar armes
i lluitar, que van dir que encara estaven en guerra,
i aquí van envair dos cops. Va ser com molt ràpid,
i la gent no
l'importava tant. Aquí el 2008
no ens recordem, perquè el 2008 va haver-hi una guerra oberta
entre Rússia i Geòrgia, que van morir molts milers
de georgians. Milers, eh?
De fet, hi ha un monument, una de les rotondes
de monument als quígons amb la guerra,
i tothom diu que, bueno, al final la guerra
es va pactar amb despatxos,
perquè si Rússia hagués volgut conquerir el país,
probablement amb dos dies
ho hauria tingut llest. De vegades hi ha
molts russos, a Tbilisi i a Batumi,
sobretot. Sí.
Amb poder exidiu molt alt, que
estan fugint de Rússia.
Fan pujar els preus aquí.
I fan pujar els preus aquí. Com els èxpats de Barcelona.
Exacte.
Exacte, una mica, sí, sí. I aquí
hi ha carrers i barris que són 100% russos.
Ah, o sigui, a més estan com una mica aquest, oi?
Ja, sí, sí, sí. Fan els seus bars,
fan els seus locals, els seus restaurants,
i els georgians estan preocupats.
Fa poc vam fer un sopar oficial d'aquest campus
que fem aquí amb el Barça Academy
i amb la Federació de Geòrgia, ens vam fer
un sopar oficial i estàvem sopant
envoltat de russos. Amb un sopar d'aquests
típics en un restaurant georgià on fan
valls georgians i
sopar típic d'aquí. I ells estaven
una mica com dient, a l'alt
of Russian, a raonar. Estaven
ple de russos. I no
estaven còmodes.
Jo ara em pensava, quan vaig venir, vaig veure,
vaig notar, com a mínim, que la majoria de gent
era del Madrid, però aquesta
vegada he vist moltíssimes més samarretes
del Barça. No sé, tu què creus? Que són més
del Barça o del Madrid, aquí? Jo crec que,
com tot, com que no tenen res de sentiment emocional,
va per tendències. El Madrid va encadenar
tres copes d'Europa i la gent es va muntar a carro
al guanyador. Però si t'has fixat, per
mig de Tbilisi hi ha anuncis de Coca-Cola
i la cara visible és la mitja mal. Ah, doncs
no m'he vist això. Hi ha un parell anant
cap al Paolló, passem un parell de carreteres
i la cara visible és la mitja mal bevent una Coca-Cola.
I penses, ostres, potser això, la
tendència potser està canviant. I si ara
al Barça aconseguís tenir èxits
esportius, doncs aquí sortirien generacions que són del Barça.
Sí. Acá, acá, acá.
Però sí que és veritat que els nanos que jo tinc, que són de 16 anys,
molts riem
perquè són del Madrid. Un tema de
conversa? Clar, el Jorge, suposo que
és impossible, no? No, no. Jorge ja
és molt difícil, és molt difícil
i ja dominem
algunes coses.
Sabem les paraules, sabem comptar números,
sabem dir esquerra, dreta, dalt o a baix,
coses que ens serveixen per nosaltres per entrenar,
però treballem en anglès. Perquè no parlen tots anglès,
suposo, que si dius això... Els nens,
la veritat és que tenen un nivell,
la meitat tenen un nivell alt
i l'altra meitat es defensen.
O sigui, és veritat que en cada grup hi ha 3 o 4
que 0, que 0, que normalment coincideix
amb els que venen de zones rurals.
Però els de la capital, t'haig de dir que
gairebé tots parlen un anglès molt, molt acceptable.
I ja no aprenen rus, no? Entenc,
ara són les... No.
Les generacions antigues són les que
tenien... Exacte. Els seus entrenadors,
quan anaven a escola, tenien una assignatura que era rus.
I els fills, o els que estan
ara amb 14 o 15 anys, aquests ja no aprenen rus.
Ja no tenen l'assignatura rus.
I els grans, la gent gran d'aquí, diuen
que haurien d'aprendre rus.
O sigui, volen ser europeus, però volen que els seus fills
aprenguin rus per la proximitat que tenen amb la frontera
i perquè, bueno, hi ha molt de negoci.
És una qüestió de temps, no? Al final, la demografia,
si hi ha els més joves tal, hi ha els més...
Correcte. Jo crec que quan aquestes generacions arribin...
Bueno, també hi falta el tema rural.
Que el tema rural, acabi aquesta idea
més pro-europea, s'acabi expandint
a les petites... Però vull dir, a Tbilisi
viu gairebé la meitat de la població, no?
No tant, no arriba, però...
És que les eleccions van ser molt ajustades.
De fet, va haver-hi també bastant
crisi
per saber si les eleccions havien estat
realment ajustades o hi havia hagut alguna cosa
rara. Però... Sí, sí.
Estava molt
polaritzada la situació.
50-50, 52-48... Bueno, una miqueta...
Alguna cosa que t'hagis
sorprès d'algun xoc cultural que diguis
ostres, això no m'ho esperava.
Home, molts.
Petites coses, no? El que et deia abans
del petó, el que et deia abans de
primer són molt tancats.
Estan reivindicant-ho constantment
al seu país. Tu, per exemple, aquí tenen una beguda
alcohòlica molt típica, que és la xatxa.
Que la xatxa, de fet, a l'etiqueta
l'etiqueten com vodka. O sigui,
posen vodka jaurjà, xatxa.
I tu els dius, això és vodka? I et diuen, no.
Això no és vodka. El vodka és rus
i nosaltres és xatxa, no?
El plat típic d'aquí és el xatxa puri, que el xatxa puri
tu el beus i aparentment és una pizza.
És semblant, no?
El format i tal. I quan
fas aquest tipus de bromes, ells sempre intenten treure
sempre la seva part de dir, no, no, això és d'aquí i tal.
I quan tu demostres
interès o
fas
que t'agrada una cosa georgiana,
ells s'emocionen. Ells realment...
Ja vam anar a veure com ballaven i realment,
hòstia, els balls, que són típics d'aquí,
que són molt espectaculars perquè són
amb salts molt grans,
on el...
L'home i la dona interactuen moltíssim,
però hi ha molta energia.
No és un ball molt tranquil, és un ball molt, molt
mogut i, clar, és que crida l'atenció.
I quan nosaltres estàvem
així com admirats pel ball,
ells miraven com dient, mira, mira, mira,
a mi com els agrada. I això és guai.
Bueno, és un país que vol
ser
reconegut internacionalment.
I els hi costa. I són molt religiosos?
Sí. Molt.
Ortodoxos la majoria. Ortodoxos la majoria, sí.
Ortodoxos la majoria, molt religiosos.
Mira, tenim una cosa amb això. Nosaltres, a l'hora
d'entrenar, els hi fem treure tot el que sigui
que pugui ser les iorrellotges,
anells... No hem aconseguit
que es treguin la creu.
És una creu de fusta amb una corda petita.
No és perillosa, és veritat, perquè és un fil,
un fil molt petit, i és una creu que porten
de fusta, però no hem aconseguit
que se'l treguin. Quan els diem, hòstia, és que això pot
enganxar-se a algú, se'l fiquen per dins
de la samarreta i fan veure que no té sentit.
Però ells no se'l treuen. I quan en competició
oficial se l'han de treure,
és ben bé, se'l treuen a l'últim moment.
Si fan-ne tot l'escalfament amb això,
i se'l treuen just abans
i se'l tornen a posar de seguida.
Deu ser una cosa dels ortodoxos en general, perquè
a Grècia també ho fan, que són ortodoxos,
també ho feien el mateix.
Portar la creu, algunes de fusta.
Sí, sí. Molts porten tatuatges
amb creus, fins i tot nens,
i, evidentment, quan passem
parlant d'una església o quan estem a prop
d'una església, assenyalen,
quan...
Els partits de l'absoluta,
i nosaltres ja ens han explicat
que hi haurà un moment que el capità ens farà fora del vestuari
i et resaran.
Sí, sí. Fan una pregària
just abans de començar a jugar.
Són molt practicants. Són religiosos, però
molt practicants. Molt practicants, sí, sí.
Segueixen molt totes les seves
normes religioses que els demarquen.
Has conegut algun català
que es queda aquí?
No. Catalans vivint aquí, no.
De turisme, cada cop més, no? Sí, catalans de turisme cada cop més.
Amb tres anys he notat moltíssim. A més,
com que la gent sap que jo estic aquí col·laborant,
molta gent t'ha demanat informació, on podem anar,
coneixes algun hotel, alguna excursió, quina zona
ens recomanes... I sí que és veritat que
m'està arribant molta més gent que vol venir cap aquí
perquè és un país emergent a nivell
turístic i a la gent que li agrada
el turisme en llocs poc turístics
aquest és un país per visitar ara.
Potser d'aquí 5-6 anys
podria no. La teva família
t'ha vingut a visitar algun dia?
No, aquí hi ha el meu fill.
No coincidir, perquè els dies no són bons.
Els dies no són bons i ara a l'estiu
coincideix amb feina de la nena
que la nena és gran. Però està previst.
El nen ha vingut per primer cop a aquest viatge
i ha fet el temps. I què li sembla? Bé, està
14 anys, farà 15 i està...
Si jo estic una mica com
en xoc el primer cop que arribes
ell també, no? El menjar és diferent,
tot és diferent, tot és diferent, les relacions són
diferents i interactuar amb els jugadors
és complicat, és complicat.
Però és una experiència... Ah, però hi juga l'embol.
Sí, hi juga l'embol i el tinc dins del campus.
Està entrenant amb els nens del campus.
Clar, amb els que parla anglès pot interactuar, però està previst
que vingui tota la família i aprofitar per fer
una mica de turisme quan vinguin.
La família del meu company, en Xevi, sí que va venir l'estiu passat
i ja van estar uns dies aquí compartint amb nosaltres
la concentració de l'embol i una mica
de turisme per la ciutat. I ja està previst
que la família vingui tan punt sigui possible.
Menjar preferit de la Georgia?
Hachapuri. Hachapuri?
Jo no m'he enamorat gaire del hachapuri, eh?
El jincali sí. El jincali, però el jincali
a mi m'ha fart el jincali. El jincali me'n puc menjar
un, dos, però més ja és allò molt repetitiu.
I no ho dic bé, no és el hachapuri,
és el hachanuri, el que té l'ou ferrat al mig.
El hachapuri
araxia, o el de
la zona de Batumi, que és una barca.
Que és com una barca, que és com una espècie
de calzone, no tancat, amb un ou
ferrat a dins i mantega, i realment és espectacular.
La cervesa que tenen aquí és correcta,
també és molt bona, és una cervesa suau,
i ells presumeixen molt del vi,
però crec que el nostre vi és millor.
A mi m'ha agradat el vi, ja veus, ja.
No he provat gaire, eh? He begut més cervesa,
m'ha agradat, sí.
Diuen que ells ho van inventar, el vi.
Sí.
Sí, sí, clar, això...
Ells diuen que abans que els grecs
ells ja produïen vi,
i que tenen vinyes molt bones,
és un vi potser amb més graus d'alcohol
que el nostre, és més fort.
El que tenen el vermell sec que diuen ells
és bo, és semblant al que podem tenir nosaltres,
però hi ha altres vins que...
els vins més suaus o els vins blancs,
a mi, personalment, no m'agraden.
Però el que he provat
que més m'agrada és el...
el vermell que diuen ells, el red dry,
i sec.
I aquest és correcte,
i amb carn entra bé.
I la cuina que tenen,
clar, han begut en molts llocs.
Ells parlen del kebab,
del seu kebab,
que dius, bueno, el teu kebab
és molt similar al turc.
Parlen de com cuinen el porc,
perquè aquí sí que mengen porc,
els musulmans...
Ho estic aprofitant per menjar porc, perquè clar,
d'aquí el que te queda...
Sí, fins a la Índia, o la Xina,
no podré tornar a menjar porc.
Porta't a la butxaca una mica.
Sí, sí, sí, aquí cuinen molt bé el porc,
cuinen molt bé el pollastre,
tenen bona vedella,
la veritat és que cuinen bé
i són de menjar compartit.
No és menjar cadascú el seu plat,
sinó d'omplir la taula
com més coses millor,
i per ells seria com una ofensa
que un cop acabem tips,
ja no quedi menjar.
O sigui, ha de sobrar menjar a la taula,
ha de sobrar menjar a la taula.
Aquesta cosa antiga, no?
Sí, aquesta cosa cultural
de que s'obri, que s'obri,
que no falti.
Ells es casen aviat?
M'ha donat la sensació.
Sí.
Tenim entrenadors
que no arriben a la trentena,
que ja tenen un,
dos,
o fins i tot n'hi ha un
que té tres fills,
que té tres fills.
Es casen aviat.
Però com pot ser que tenen fills,
tal, tal,
però després,
en un poble,
una nació tan petita,
amb tantes poques persones,
com s'explica això?
Perquè hi ha molta gent
que se'n va cap a fora.
Doncs això ja sí que se m'escapa.
Les oportunitats no són bones,
t'has dit que la majoria de gent
o és classe alta o baixa.
Sí.
Hi ha molta diàspora, no?
Sí, hi ha molta gent
que aprofita per estudiar a fora
o fer la universitat a fora.
O sigui, tu tens gent a la selecció
que no visca a Jòrgia?
La majoria.
Ostres.
Els jugadors de selecció?
La majoria, selecció absoluta,
aquí no poden viure davant molt.
Aquí no poden viure.
Estan a la Lliga Francesa,
a la Lliga Alemana,
a Polònia,
a Romania,
en tenim tres o quatre,
i després als Països Bàltics,
Macedònia,
Sèrbia, Croàcia,
que també hi ha molt d'envol,
doncs van allà a jugar
a equips que els contracten,
equips que els contracten.
I venen aquí?
Venen aquí quan fan la concentració.
O sigui, com nosaltres,
ells arriben, de fet,
a vegades coincidim a l'aeroport,
arribem a l'aeroport
i amb el vol de París
venen dos d'ells.
Vull dir que si és aquí,
a la que tenen 18-19 anys,
la seva possibilitat dins de l'envol
és marxar.
De fet, ara tenim dos,
tres jugadors georgians
que els portarem a la Lliga Espanyola,
a dos o tres equips,
a provar-los,
per veure si algun d'aquests equips
els convenç i els contracten.
O sigui, els hi fem una miqueta
també de gent.
Enteneu.
Ha passat el que anem.
Amb aquesta hora?
Sí.
Ha penjat.
Última pregunta.
Selecció femenina.
Ostres.
No sé si és molt incipient o...
Molt incipient.
De fet, selecció femenina absoluta
ara mateix no n'hi ha.
Vaja.
No en tenen.
Perquè les últimes noies
que estaven jugant,
què passa?
Tornem al que els he dit abans.
Es casen molt aviat
i tenen fills molt aviat.
Per tant, aquestes noies
que amb 18, 21, 22 anys,
hi ha molt d'abandonament
de l'esport femení.
Això passava a Catalunya fa anys,
però ara per sort no.
Però aquí encara passa
que als 18, 19, 20 anys,
moltes noies diuen
jo ja he jugat en vol,
jo ja he fet el que volia fer
amb el món de l'envol,
jo ara ho deixo
i em dedico a treballar,
a viure amb la meva família
i a crear una família.
Això amb els homes no passa
i allarga més la seva carrera esportiva.
I aquí sí que tenim jugadors
amb 28, 29, 30, 32 anys
que encara són professionals
del món de l'envol,
que han tingut criatures
però segueixen sent professionals
de l'envol.
La dona queda tallada abans aquí.
Per tant, la selecció absoluta femenina
ara mateix no en tenen.
Sí que tenen júnior, juvenil i cadet.
Bé.
Molt interessant.
A pesar de no viure al 100% a Georgia
crec que coneixes bastant bé el país.
Hem vingut moltes vegades
i els que ens acullen
són molts georgians
i tenen moltes ganes
d'explicar el seu país.
Recomanaries per final
que la gent vingués a Georgia
a visitar?
Sí.
Si us agrada la muntanya,
si us agrada la muntanya
és un país per descobrir muntanya,
muntanya de 4.000 i 5.000 metres,
verge,
amb pobles petits,
molt xulos per visitar
i que a més a més
t'acolliran de manera fabulosa.
Si us agrada el bon menjar
i el bon vi
i la bona cervesa,
doncs aquí es pot venir
i disfrutar de la gastronomia del país.
I a més a més
és un lloc per fer,
a part del trekking d'alta muntanya,
es pot fer molt de trekking també
sense haver d'agafar grans pics.
O sigui, si no us van els grans pics
també es pot fer.
La part de platja de Batumi
potser és més comercial,
potser és més...
Grans resorts.
Aquí li diuen Las Vegas
d'aquesta part d'aquí.
Sí, sí, perquè
hi ha molts països musulmans
que no poden jugar
i venen aquí a jugar.
Venen aquí a Batumi,
a casinos i tal,
i per això li diuen una mica Las Vegas.
Grans edificis,
tots els resorts americans i europeus
tenen una seu aquí.
És la part de Batumi,
potser és la que menja.
A mi personalment m'agrada
que és la de pulserita
i disfrutar del resort.
Però per fer trekking,
per fer natura,
per fer animals,
per fer grans rius,
grans espectacles de la natura,
és un país per descobrir ara
i potser d'aquí uns anys
hi estarà més.
I compta amb els gossos.
I compta amb els gossos,
això ja m'ho ha explicat.
Bé, molt bé.
Moltes gràcies a tu,
un plaer.
Moltes gràcies.
Enric, molta sort
i que tinguis un bon viatge
i et seguirem pel vídeo.
Igualment,
que vagi bé.
Perfecte.